je me tourne vers machin qui est
propriétaire d'un magasin de jouets à
tarbes alors il ya deux chiffres qui
voit là résume le problème de votre
profession 770 millions d'euros de
perdus si les magasins de jouets ne
rouvre pas avant noël et entre novembre
et décembre le secteur du jouet réalise
près de la moitié de ses ventes
annuelles 48% donc vos l'enjeu du 1er
décembre de cet aboutissement il est
crucial complètement crucial en angola
il faut vous parliez très près du micro
complètement crucial on va là on fait 50
% de notre chiffre sur deux mois je vois
pas trop comment on peut voilà comment
on peut continuer si on est fermé alors
déjà en heures pleines
en novembre il faut à tout prix qu'à
partir de décembre en fils
ré ouvrir avec un protocole sanitaire
peut-être plus strict ça y'a pas de
soucis après moi ce qui me heurte c'est
que dans ce confinement
il ya beaucoup d'incohérences et c'est
ça qui nous qui nous qui nous met la
rage je suis venu en train moi
aujourd'hui dans leur dans le wagon on
était 48 voyageurs un wagon de tgv ça
fait quarante neuf mètres carrés moi je
peux pas ouvrir un magasin très bons
arguments
je peux passer quatre heures à côté d'un
mec que je connais tant qu' à 20
centimètres de moi est avec 47 autres
personnes
on a un mètre carré c'est pas logique et
c'est que des choses comme ça en fait
c'est tout est illogique
je peux aller chez mon caviste acheter
du pain je les adore j'en suis très
contente
mais chez moi on peut pas venir acheter
un jeu quelque chose d'irrationnel
mais c'est la vienne qui est logique
c'est même la double peine pour vous
parce que les jouets que vous ne vendez
pas il se vend d'ailleurs alors
apparaître de grandes surfaces a l'air
un peu louche le dispositif à lyon et
puis il ya des plateformes dont on ne
citera pas le nom qui elle distribue le
jeu juste entendre la fin de match et
ensuite
ouais il ya des plateformes qui
distribue ou tout simplement d'un fait
une règle c'est un drive vous pouvez
acheter des jouets en drive nous on
inventerait nos stocks donc les stocks
ils sont là les jouets sont là mais
voilà les lutins nous on est à l'arrêt
mais pour qui est quand même une note
positive est ce que vous dans votre
magasin ou plus généralement à l'échelle
de la profession vous avez mis en place
dès ce qu'on appelle le click and
collect ex-cat des moyens d'échapper au
tout ou rien que quand je dis le rien
c'est à dire les plateformes dont on ne
veut pas citer le nom ici alors moi je
me suis lancé dans un site pendant le
premier confinement en fait j'ai
contacté une agence de com - site sortie
là le lundi on a été confiné le jeudi
soir
donc quand je les ai contactés je leur
ai dit je veux faire un site avant
l'automne en prévision d'un second
confinement tout le monde rigolait au
final c'est ce qui se passe ça ne me
permets de bricoler mais le voilà dans
le secteur du jouet 70% des achats se
font en boutique
parce qu'il a besoin d'un accompagnement
il ya besoin de conseils et a besoin de
vous
les choses du coup ouais là on bricole
mais on ne peut pas faire noël comme ça
j'imagine bien mais je voudrais quand
même en appeler à des réflexes citoyens
ne pas croire qu'il n'ya pas de solution
si on se donne un peu la peine on peut
acheter ces jouets auprès de commerces
indépendants on est tous jouent tous le
jeu tout le monde n'a pas de site comme
moi mais on répond aux appels on prépare
des commandes
enfin on est là non mais tout ne doit
pas venir du gouvernement il ya une
responsabilité individuelle plutôt faire
des achats chez vous qu'ailleurs c'est
ce que les gens veulent d'ailleurs il
donc va très bien qian c'est terrible
dans ce deuxième confinement eric c'est
que ce n'est pas un confinement
ce sont d empêcher qu'ils regardent
d'eysines empêcher l est au travail
c'est un empêchement pour certains et un
autobus qui était considéré dans le
premier comme quelque chose de
sanitaires aujourd'hui considérée et qui
est quelque chose qui est considéré
comme punitif voir vexatoire parce que
moi j'ai pas l'impression qu'on soit
confier un confinement sa porte bien son
nom
si vous sortez vous mourrez c'est un peu
l'ambiance dans laquelle on était en
mars
la peste et le choléra fromage et
dessert aujourd'hui on voit bien que à
peu près tout le monde se promène dans
la rue à peu près tout le monde à
certaines heures mais il ya du monde il
ya plus de mon nom mais il ya beaucoup
plus de monde que pendant l'un parce que
ce n'est pas le cas chez vous on a
oublié qu'au mois de mars entre 18h et
19h on avait droit devait faire son
footing points il y avait c'était la
guerre nucléaire à l'extérieur
aujourd'hui vous êtes à paris
vous avez l'impression qu'on est en
provinces et une ville de province qui
vit agences rapho
c'est pas faux j'ai l'impression que ça
il ya beaucoup moins de monde que
d'habitude quand j'ai l'impression qu'on
est à chartres où un revers 1 dimanche
soir alors que c'est un samedi
après-midi mais ça veut dire qu'il ya du
monde et donc qu'est-ce qui se passe
s'il ya peu de monde c'est parce que des
gens qui voudraient travailler ne
peuvent pas or toute la semaine ils
voient les deux autres aller au travail
donc est quelque chose qui revient à
créer deux france celle qui a le droit
d'aller au travail et celles qui en a
qui n'a pas le droit donc les paralysés
et les mobiles